después de casi tres años de llevar
mascarillas tanto dentro como fuera
llegó el momento que muchos residentes
de Hong Kong estaban esperando
Desde el miércoles la ciudad ya no
obliga a llevar la cara cubierta salvo
en zonas de alto riesgo como hospitales
y residencias de ancianos
creo que han hecho bien en cancelar el
mandato de las mascarillas la gente
puede volver a respirar aire fresco y
mantener conversaciones cara a cara sin
mascarillas
es un cambio radical para una ciudad que
imponía multas de 600 euros a quienes no
llevaban mascarilla pero algunos
junconeses se resisten a renunciar a lo
que se ha convertido en un accesorio
imprescindible tengo mascarillas en casa
y sigo un poco preocupado por la
situación de la pandemia Así que
probablemente seguiré llevando las
durante un tiempo más
las autoridades locales esperan que la
decisión fomente el turismo en Hong Kong
y reactive la economía golpeada por la
recesión
con la supresión de requisito de
mascarillas empezamos a recuperar la
normalidad de forma generalizada lo que
será muy beneficioso para el desarrollo
económico y la competitividad
internacional
Lugares cercanos como Macao suprimieron
la obligatoriedad de cubrirse la cara en
interiores en días anteriores a su vez
Corea del Sur puso fin al requisito en
enero mientras que Singapur suavizó aún
más las normas hace dos semanas